So in the last 24 hours, we have seen these
allegations made coming out of Michael Schmidt's
forthcoming book that when Donald Trump was
rushed to Walter Reed Medical Center in 2019,
it was not that he decided to get ahead on
his 20-20 physical.
We suspected that from day one because it
didn't make any sense. But Michael Schmidt
is saying that something medical was taking
place and that it was serious enough that
Mike Pence was told in case Trump has to be
put under anesthesia, be on standby, be ready
to take the helm as as as temporary president
of the United States. So Donald Trump raised
without prompting that he didn't really have
a stroke on that day. Now, that was weird
because it hasn't been alleged that Trump
had a stroke on that day. But let's put the
Trump piece aside and focus on Mike Pence.
Now, Mike Pence was interviewed yesterday
on Fox News by Bret Baer. Bret Baer, to his
credit, asks the simple and straightforward
question. Is it true that you were put on
standby in case Donald Trump had to be put
under anesthesia that day? The answer does
not inspire confidence. Take a look at what
Mike Pence had to say.
The candidate from another party. This refers
to Michael Schmidt's book where he says the
president went to Walter Reed, which in fact
happened in November of last year. He says
in the book that you were put on alert to
take control, to take office, essentially
if he went under for anesthesia. Is that true?
President Donald Trump is in excellent health.
And Bret, I'm always informed of the president's
movements and whether it was on that day or
any other day and for him. But there was no
there was nothing out of the ordinary about
that moment or or that day. And I just refer
the other questions to the White House physician
as far as being on standby.
So the question is, were you put on alert
in case Trump needed to be put under general
anesthesia? And Mike Pence doesn't say no.
Mike Pence says Trump is an excellent. Health,
I I'm always informed as to where Trump is
and what Trump is doing, and nothing out of
the ordinary took place and go talk to the
White House doctor about how healthy Donald
Trump is, not an answer that inspires confidence.
In fact, when I hear Mike Pence say anything
but know, what I'm hearing is yes. But Bret
Beyer tries again. Take a look at what happened.
As far as being on standby, I don't I don't
recall being told to be on standby. I I was
informed that the president had a doctor's
appointment, and I want that. I must do it,
but I just want to go. I got to tell you,
part of this job is you're always on standby
is your vice president of the United States.
But the American people can be confident that
this president is in remarkably good health.
And every single day I see that energy and
high relief on talk of I don't recall being
told to be on stand by, says Mike Pence. If
you know how politicians lie and avoid answering
questions. This is Mike Pence making it a
semantic linguistic argument. He doesn't recall
being told. And the word used was not stand
by. That's what Mike Pence wants us to believe.
And then he goes back to this refrain of Trump
is in great health. These are not denials,
my friends. If I had to sum up what Mike Pence
is saying, if I run what Mike Pence is saying
through a politician of decoding device, Mike
Pence is saying, yeah, that's what happened
and I don't want to talk about it. No sane
person could realistically watch that answer
and think that Mike Pence is answering truthfully.
If someone is asked a yes or no question and
they talk and they talk and they talk without
answering the question, then the most likely
answer is the one that would be most embarrassing,
which in this case would be, yes, it is true.
We lied. Trump didn't go to Walter Reed for
a physical. Trump was abruptly rushed to the
hospital. There was the possibility general
anesthesia would be needed. And I was briefed
to be on alert for that. He starts the answer
with the biggest lie. Think back to that.
He is asked about whether this took place.
And he says the president is in great health.
We know that's not true. Donald Trump is obese.
He's medicated for high cholesterol. And he
eats a terrible diet of fast food and doesn't
exercise. So it starts with a completely obvious
lie and gets worse from there. So we should
continue to be careful not to make specific
assertions about what happened when these
are not the allegations that anybody within
sight is making. So when Trump denies that
he had a stroke, we shouldn't say, oh, he
definitely had a stroke, but it should raise
our suspicion because it hasn't been alleged.
Trump is the one raising the idea of a stroke.
And that's what's the biggest red flag here.
Let me know what you think. I'm on Twitter
at David Pakman.
What do you make of Donald Trump's tweet denying
he had a stroke which had not been alleged?
And Mike Pence refusing to answer the simple
question. Let me know what you think. I'm
on Twitter at David Pakman.